lots of uh authors on the on the show
tonight and you'll all know
how important a presentation is for a
book you know just sometimes
a carelessly placed sticker can
make a kid's book well less of a kid's
book like
this story uh tuck me in
oops
little little wonder this particular
caterpillar is
so popular
it was as long as his body
here's a twist on little house on the
prairie
well you know
[Applause]
just for clarification this next book is
actually called
my daddy is a giant
[Applause]
well no i um you know
the bit on the television where it tells
you about the program little information
box
oh yes well i was um doing the voiceover
for it'll be all right on the night
and the text was meant to say david
williams reveals his toe curling
cock-ups
but they didn't have enough room so it
just went david williams reveals his toe
curling [ __ ]
it may not be the prettiest one you've
seen but
i mean please a lot more people tuned in
to watch
[Applause]
did you viewers went through the route
[Music]